[MUSIC PLAYING]
VISHAL GOENKA: Thank
you for coming.
My name is Vishal Goenka.
I'm a product manager at Google.
I'm responsible for
growing our Maps API
business in key verticals
by enabling our partners
and our customers build
compelling businesses powered
by Google's Geo services.
Today it is my privilege
to talk to you about some
of the key
location-related challenges
that the on-demand
economy is facing.
Now, powered by smartphones,
a number of industries
have been disrupted
in the space.
And they have generated new
user behaviors and expectations
in the process.
Today what I will do is I will
examine the impact of some
of these new user expectations
and behaviors created
by location-enabled
services, on-demand services,
and the impact of that on the
economics of these businesses,
and what opportunities lies
ahead of us as we go forward.
I'm going to focus
on two specific areas
of this economy-- the
local rides and delivery.
Let me start by asking
you a very simple question
to get a sense of the audience.
How many of you here have used
a local ride service in the US?
A delivery service
recently in the US
where you've have had food
delivered or groceries
delivered?
What about outside the US?
What about Europe?
OK.
Africa?
One.
How about Latin America?
Southeast Asia?
Australia?
So very few outside
of the United States
and possibly Europe.
Some of the things I'm going
to talk about apply more
in certain geographies
than others,
but there is a common thread.
Let me begin first
with a personal story.
About three to four
years ago, I was
at the Google office in New
York City for a meeting,
and I had to catch a flight back
at 7:00 PM to San Francisco.
I wrapped up my
meetings by 3 o'clock
and I headed down
to catch a taxi.
It was raining.
And after waiting for
30 minutes in the rain,
I finally decided
to take the train,
and I barely made it
to the airport on time.
I later realized why I could
not get a cab that day.
Because of the rain, the
cabbies had made their money
earlier in the day
because of higher demand
and called it a day.
Now, there was no
way back then I
could monitor the
inventory of drivers
on the road in real time
and not being a local
could have predicted that this
would be an expected pattern.
Apparently, the locals
could have predicted this
because they have
faced it a few times.
Now, when I travel
to India, which
is where I was born and raised
and I still have extended
family there, if I
needed to move around,
I would hire a car for the
entire day with a driver.
Because finding a cab where
you need it and when you need
it was impossible.
Today, on the other hand, I
sit comfortably in my office,
maybe as I'm wrapping up my
last meeting for the day,
or I'm at the terminal
of an airport getting
ready to pick up my bags, and I
can see how long it would take
for the next ride to arrive.
I can schedule it ahead of time.
And if it's raining,
I can actually
show up just moments before
my ride actually arrives.
In the last few
years, I've traveled
over half a dozen
countries and have
had very similar experiences
across all of those countries.
Let's switch gears
to ordering food.
We normally eat out,
but sometimes when
we bring food
home, it used to be
that I would look in my
drawers for printed menus
that I received in the mail
from various restaurants
or looked up their menu
online, if they had one,
and then I would call them.
But then either the
menus were out of date,
the prices were
out of date, or I
had to plan a trip to go to
the restaurant, which limited
my choices to only
restaurants that
were within the range of
my willingness to drive.
There simply weren't
enough delivery options
that would deliver unless
you had a really huge order.
Today I browse rich
menus on the phone.
I can order all
sorts of cuisines--
Italian, Indian, Chinese,
Vietnamese, Japanese--
and I can be assured that they
will arrive when I need it to.
I can be at the
soccer game of my kids
and order food knowing that by
the time the kids have returned
and showered the food will be
at our doorstep ready to munch.
If my kids want cheese
pizza, and my wife
and I prefer something
else, perhaps Thai,
we can place two separate
orders and have them
be delivered at the same time.
I don't know how many of you
were at Gayathri's session
yesterday, but if you were,
she spoke about location
as a force multiplier.
And she gave examples of how
many businesses, including
companies in the local
rides and delivery space,
have built amazing businesses
and created new user
experiences by leveraging
Google's incredibly
rich and complex understanding
of the real world.
Now, traditional
taxi drivers did not
need a map to navigate the
cities that they served.
They had developed
their hippocampus area
of their memory because
of the spatial knowledge
that they had to develop
in order to navigate
the world without maps.
Now, once maps got
digitized, some of them
started switching and
using Maps as a tool
when they needed to go
somewhere they didn't know.
However, today even
though I know the route
that I commute every day
and I know my way back home,
I still check Google
Maps every day.
Because sometimes there
is a more efficient route.
Maybe there is an accident
or an unfortunate incident
on the road.
Or perhaps the 49ers
are playing nearby
and the roads are jammed.
And Google Maps is able
to tell me in real time
an alternate route that is
more effective for my journey.
If as some of you have tried
these ride sharing services
in other countries,
not just the US,
you'd have probably seen the
familiar Google-powered maps
driving many of these
companies today.
We have a very rich
set of APIs that
enable developers
and our partners
build these applications
across multiple platforms,
whether it's iOS, or Android,
a good old website using
JavaScript, or web services to
enable access to our services
through your servers.
Today we have over 3 million
developers and over 10,000
paying customers using our
APIs to build everything
from visualizing
a point on a map,
to routing for deliveries or
rides, or even programming
television remotes based on the
location that the device is at.
Yesterday, Vagabond was
here, and they gave us
an example of how they
used Google's APIs
to program automatic
vending machines
and simplified the workflow for
their workforce significantly
and saved a lot of
money in the process.
Looking forward, we're
building on these capabilities
and bringing together
all of our real time
and historical
knowledge of the world
and combining it with our
machine learning and cloud
computing to bring
new predictive powers
for our customers, bringing
new insights, as well as
predictive capabilities.
But in order to understand where
this takes us in the future,
let's focus on the user.
At Google, we strongly believe
that if you focus on the user,
all things become clear.
So speaking of local
rides and deliveries,
reflecting back on the habits
that have changed for me--
and I'm sure for many of you--
the ease with which
these habits changed
did not surprise me until I
stopped to think about it.
My first experience with
these ride-sharing services
was a magical one,
even though it took me
a little bit of overcoming
the inertia to try them.
It was such a magical
experience that I got hooked.
Over the last 100-plus years
since Ford invented the Model-T
and changed transportation
in a fundamental way,
we have developed a number
of habits around mobility.
Let's take a quick walk
down the memory lane
and examine some
of these and how
they have changed over time.
In most country-- well,
in many countries,
I wouldn't say most-- in many
countries around the world,
car ownership is a very
common habit that many of us
grew up with, even though we
all understand that owning a car
is not the most
economical decision you
could make for mobility.
Most of our cars spend most
of their time sitting idle.
And that garage that we dedicate
a huge fraction of our house
to store the car while it
is not being productive
does cost a lot of money.
And if you add the cost
of gas, maintenance,
the payments for
the car, insurance,
it's not the most
economical decision.
And on top of it, we
have developed the habit
of spending hours behind
the steering wheel
when we could have done
something more useful.
When we were called upon to
hire a ride for a short drive,
we have created a whole
institution and a protocol
around this notion.
So we call it taxis,
or cabs, or taxi cabs.
Let's examine some of the
protocols we have developed.
These cars are painted
differently so that we can
recognize them from a distance.
They have special signs on them
that you can read from afar
and know whether you
can hire them or not.
In airports, we have dedicated
signs and special queues--
sometimes really long ones--
and people there to
manage the queues.
Hotels have a special
protocol and a special area
for getting people
in and out of taxis.
In many countries,
there are special lanes
that taxis can
drive on, or they're
allowed to drive in bus lanes.
There are special,
designated areas
where taxis can park that
nobody else can park,
or where you would
go to find the cab.
And last but not least,
there's a familiar hand gesture
to hail a cab that
we have developed,
and it may vary from one
culture to the other.
Contrasting with the ride
sharing experience of today,
we schedule our
rides from our phone
regardless of where we are.
Once we have scheduled
the ride, finding
how to find the specific
car that is assigned to you
requires a very new protocol.
You expect to call the driver,
or the driver to call you,
in many cases.
Your car could be
a Toyota Corolla
or a minivan
indistinguishable from any
of the other cars on the road.
And you really wish you had
eagle eyes to spot that license
plate from a distance so
that you know it's your ride.
Once the car arrives,
we have told ourselves
it's OK if the driver does
not get out of the car
to handle our bags for us.
For all we know, he might be
a regular Joe just like you
and me, or a student
doing this part time,
or a person with a desk job.
And then, once we arrive
at our destination,
we have accustomed
ourselves to not
bother about ensuring that we
have enough cash in our pocket,
or whether or not the driver is
going to accept a credit card.
So a number of these
habits, small ones,
have changed as a result
of this transformation.
The first time I ordered
a ride for somebody else,
it was even more magical.
A cousin of mine
was visiting us,
and she was going to
spend the weekend with us.
She landed in San Jose, but I
had an unavoidable conflict,
and I could not go
there to pick her up.
So I ordered a ride
to show up as soon
as she arrived at the airport.
I took a screenshot of my
app, and I texted it to her,
and she arrived home just
as when I did from work.
It was, again, another
magical experience
enabled by the service.
And of course,
now when I travel,
I don't bother with car
rentals as much as I used to.
How many of you here have
shared a ride with a stranger?
I'm pretty sure many of you
did not do this back in the day
when you were
riding in taxicabs.
It was not a very
common thing to get
into a taxicab with a stranger.
And yet, this is not a
millennial phenomena.
Millennials are known to--
or are expected to--
are stereotyped with
putting their entire life
on social media.
And so we expect them to be very
comfortable with sharing rides
with strangers.
But clearly, we have a fairly
reasonable sample here,
and in talking with drivers
as well as our partners
across many countries, we
have found that it's not
a millennial phenomena.
How about commuting to
work using a ride sharing
service, anyone?
This is relatively less
common at the moment.
I also know a few
of my colleagues
at Google who have
sold their second cars
and are using ride sharing
exclusively to get to work.
Our habits-- our habits
dictated the principles
by which we assign value
to products or services.
Here's another
story that I'm going
to tell you that many of you
road warriors will probably
relate to.
When I first got Wi-Fi on
a plane, I was like, wow,
I don't know what to
do with this thing.
I mean, my plane rides
were read a book,
maybe listen to an audio book,
watch a movie, or just relax.
And the first time I got
Wi-Fi, I was like, wow,
I can have a communication,
real-time communication,
with my family, with
my colleagues at work
and impress them that I'm
still working at 35,000 feet.
But now, if I'm on
a long-haul flight
and I'm going to a
place for a meeting,
I actually plan to
work during that time.
I identify the parts
of the work that I'm
going to finish when
I'm on the plane.
And I see a few heads nodding.
So if I don't get Wi-Fi, or if
the Wi-Fi is not fast enough
to help me come through
an image-heavy slide deck,
I'm really disappointed.
So the value that I have
placed on that Wi-Fi
is significantly different
now that my habits
require a Wi-Fi on a plane.
Now, while Moore's
law has kept up
the advances in
technology-related products
at an accelerating
pace, as consumers,
our expectations and our
habits have not only adapted,
but very quickly
exceeded the capability
of technology very soon.
Let me give you a few examples.
20 years ago, our expectation
for on-demand, digital content
was limited to getting access
to your short messages,
your emails, anytime, anywhere.
But today, we expect the
latest Hollywood blockbusters
in ultra-high definition to be
accessible anytime, anywhere
we are.
What's more, now we
expect a real person
to show up on our doorstep,
or wherever we are,
within minutes of
summoning them.
If you're hungry for something,
we expect freshly prepared food
from our favorite
restaurant, even
if it's a hole-in-the-wall,
to show up within an hour
of desiring it.
On the computational
side, it used to be,
maybe 10, 12 years ago, that
we expected a supercomputer
to be able to crunch through
lots of data, petabytes
of data, and answer our
very structured queries
within a fraction of a second.
And today, we expect a device
that fits in our pockets,
costs probably less than
$50, to understand us,
to be able to predict our
needs even before we fully
express them.
We expect to have a
conversation with these devices.
Yesterday, you saw during the
keynote an example of that.
We expect them to
personalize their responses
based on understanding us.
And how much are we willing
to pay for all this?
Not a lot.
It started with digital content.
We first got used to getting
unlimited digital content,
whether it was unlimited
voice, unlimited data,
unlimited music, unlimited
videos at a fixed price.
And now we expect
physical services
and unlimited quantities
at a fixed price.
Unlimited shipping,
unlimited taxi rides--
it's being tried out
in a few countries,
the idea of unlimited taxi
rides for a fixed price.
We used to put a huge
premium on personalization,
on a personalized service.
Today, your cab
driver addresses you
by first name when
you meet him or her,
or can personalize the
music to your liking
as soon as you get in the car.
And we just expect it.
So my second point is that
the consumer principles
dictate the economics
of these businesses.
Price has always been
a very important driver
of consumer adoption.
And in the
ride-sharing space, we
have seen that a
number of companies
have innovated on low
cost product categories
in order to drive adoption.
And they have actually
seen very good results
with lower cost categories.
Delivery providers also
have seen higher adoption
with lower cost deliveries.
So it should come as
no surprise to you
that user expectations
from these services
and their willingness to pay are
headed in opposite directions.
Now, even as
consumers' willingness
to pay for these
services is reducing,
the companies who are
enabling these experiences
have to make enough
money so that when
the venture capital dries out,
they can sustain the business.
The suppliers of services in
this economy, the drivers,
the full-time drivers or
the part-time drivers,
they will make less as
a result on a per ride
basis, on a per mile basis.
But overall, they will make more
because of higher utilization
enabled by efficiencies
that the system brings.
But I digressed.
Let me come back to user
experience for a moment.
A few months ago,
my family and I
were returning from a vacation.
We landed in San Francisco
airport around midnight.
It was cold.
Our kids were with us.
And we waited to order
our ride until after we
had picked our
bags because there
was some uncertainty in how
long it would take for our bags
to arrive.
Once we ordered our ride,
it took eight minutes.
And we were there in the
cold, on the curbside,
waiting for our car to arrive
for about eight minutes.
Not a big deal, possibly.
But we're not the only ones.
We had other co-passengers
who were in a similar boat.
It was around
midnight, after all.
When we got in the car,
I asked the driver,
and he said he too was
waiting in the parking lot
at the airport,
or in the waiting
lot, for several minutes before
he got a call for the ride.
I know we have the ability
today to predict traffic
in future based on
learnings of the patterns
through machine learning,
big data, cloud computing, et
cetera.
And I know it is
very hard to predict
when a given passenger who
walks out of the airplane
will emerge on the curbside.
But I'm sure there are
large opportunities here
to reduce that wait time
both for the passengers
and for the drivers.
And it's not only
about user experience.
It affects the bottom line.
Let's imagine that a driver
saves two minutes on average
on a typical, average
ride of 20 minutes.
In an eight-hour day, he would
deliver 2.2 additional rides
by shaving off just
a couple of minutes
per ride on a daily basis.
That means a 10% increase
in net pay for the driver.
And that 10% goes straight
to the bottom line
of the ride-sharing companies
because the marginal cost
of that service is very minimal.
This brings us back to
the question of economics.
As consumers' willingness
to pay is going down
for these services, and their
expectations are increasing,
what levers do ride-sharing
and delivery companies
have to increase or to
improve their economics?
And we think that the answer
is efficiency at scale.
So efficiency is key to
delivering the economics that
is needed by ride-sharing
and delivery companies
in order to satisfy the consumer
principles, the expectations,
the behaviors that
customers expect because
of the new habits that
they have developed
as a result of these
location-powered ride-sharing
and delivery services.
Now let's examine some of
the key drivers of efficiency
in this space.
We're all familiar with
the notion of last mile.
Last mile in the
delivery space typically
refers to taking the goods
from warehouse to your home
and delivering it.
Given the prevalence of
ride-sharing and delivery
companies around the world, over
600 countries around the world,
it should be fairly obvious
that the efficiency bottleneck
is not about the
last mile anymore.
It has shifted to the last
1/10 of a mile, what I
would call the last deci-mile.
Let me illustrate this
with a few examples.
When you order your
ride, the driver usually
has no trouble getting
to within 1/10 of a mile
from where you are.
But typically, getting to
exactly where you are often
requires a phone call or
more than one phone call.
And if you're in
a foreign country,
that phone call could be
very expensive both for you
and for the driver.
Because we haven't
quite perfected
all the details
required to make sure
that the driver arrives
exactly where you are.
If you are here in Moscone
Center and you order a ride,
Moscone Center
has Howard Street,
which is a one-way on one end.
Oh, by the way, this
is Moscone West,
so you have to know that this
is Moscone West, and not Moscone
North, or Moscone South.
But then there are
two one-way streets.
And it has doors on both sides.
It's not sufficient to have your
driver come to Moscone Center.
They need to know
exactly which route
to take so they are on the
right side of the one-way street
in order to arrive at
the exit where you are.
Now, this can be
extremely frustrating
if you are in a new
place as a rider
and you don't know yourself
exactly where you are,
let alone explain
that to a driver.
And if you don't speak
the driver's language--
it has happened to me a couple
of times, once in Japan,
once in Latin America--
that can be even
more frustrating.
And how exactly does
the driver get to you?
Has anyone had an
experience where
you could see the building
where you needed to go
but just couldn't
find how to get there?
And you went in circles
trying to figure out the entry
point to the building?
Recently, a colleague
of mine was in the city.
And she ordered a
ride and happened
to be standing at a bus stop.
The car pulled over,
she got into the car,
and noticed there was a bus
coming right behind her.
And the bus had a camera in the
front, and she was intrigued.
Later, she found out, when she
had another co-passenger join
her for that ride share, she
learned that the buses now
have cameras so
that they can record
which cars are parked at bus
stops or stop at bus stops.
So the driver would probably be
expecting a ticket in the mail.
Ouch.
Of course, if you're
a regular taxi driver,
you would probably
know these rules.
But if you're a regular
Joe doing this part-time,
it's very unlikely that you
would know all these rules.
How long exactly will
it take to get there?
When you order your car,
or you order your food
to be delivered, the
company has to look
at the supply, the suppliers,
the drivers who are around you,
and find the driver who's
closest to you for whom
it is most efficient to get
to you as soon as possible,
which requires very
precise prediction of how
long the driver will
take to get to you.
Because not having
that answer correctly
could mean longer
wait time for you
as a passenger and probably
a suboptimal job allocation
to a driver.
Perhaps another
driver could have
done that job faster and
probably yielded a higher
return overall.
So knowing exactly how long it
takes to get to a pick-up point
makes a huge impact
to the bottom line
once you aggregate it over
millions and millions of rides
every day.
Even as a consumer we
don't like to wait.
And you're probably all familiar
with airlines and hotels who
have increased the
value of less wait time
by giving their premier
customers special lanes
to get into the airplane fast,
even though the airplane is not
going to take off any faster,
or check in faster at the hotel.
Riders today expect
to be picked up
where they are even if
that point is not exactly
on the map.
If you are in a
big shopping mall,
and you happen to exit out
of the gate, a small gate
at the back of the mall that
is flanked by two large stores,
so it's hardly even
visible on the map,
that's where to expect
the driver to arrive.
If you're in a large
office complex,
you want the driver
to pick you up
right outside as you walk
outside your office building.
If you want food to
be delivered to you,
you want it right
outside your apartment
even if that means the
driver has to figure out
where exactly to park
and how exactly to walk
from there to the
place where you expect
the food to be delivered.
Sure, we can drop
a point on a map.
We can do that very effectively.
Drop a pin on the map and
assume it'll all just work out.
But dropping a pin
on a map gives you
a latitude and a
longitude, which
is very hard for
us humans to parse.
So the example of Moscone
Center, just dropping
a latitude and longitude is
not sufficient for the driver
to know that you are
on the Howard Street
side of the Moscone Center
and you're waiting right
outside the middle entrance.
So converting that
information to something
that human beings can understand
requires a vast knowledge
at a granularity that
is finer than what
we have developed today.
And while it is helpful to
know where every place is,
even if it is a
smaller place, you
want to know is that place--
if you're going someplace,
say you're going to a
bar with your friends.
Before you go there, you want to
make sure that the place still
exists, it is still there, that
it is open, that it is busy.
Nobody wants to go to
a bar that is not busy.
But it's not too
busy that you can't
make your way to the
bartender for 15 minutes.
And of course, is
it worth going?
Is that place worth going?
There's a lot of
information about location
that is needed at a scale--
at a global scale--
in order to support
the economy, the space.
The real world
isn't static either.
It changes from one
second to the next.
And we have done
a phenomenal job
in knowing the traffic patterns
with real-time traffic.
But there's a lot
that needs to be done.
As the flow of businesses,
as new businesses open, flow
of people to businesses
change, there's
a lot of this
information that is
essential to making
the right decisions
in an efficient manner.
Has anyone ever
experienced a situation
where they found that a road
that was recommended by the map
took you through a barricade
because the road was barricaded
off for some event?
And we thought, oh, there's
no traffic here, probably
the fastest way to get across.
Or a road that has had been
washed away by the storm
the previous night?
So there's a lot of real-time
changes, real-time events that
are happening the world over,
and knowing them precisely
is important for the
efficiency that is required
for these companies to thrive.
So we are really excited by the
opportunities, the challenges
and the opportunities that are
presented in order to make it
seamless and
delightful regardless
of the circumstances.
So there are three key
pillars of efficiency
that I've discussed.
The last deci-mile efficiency,
knowing the places,
knowing every
place on the planet
at a granularity that is
much finer than before.
And we've done a tremendous
job of indexing places
the world over.
And while what we have
is not comprehensive,
it is probably the
best that exists.
And yet, we need to
go one level deeper.
We not only need to go
broader to have more coverage,
but we also need to
go one level deeper
to get to that exactness, to the
preciseness that I was talking
about, and make sure that all
of the real-time information
is even more enriched with
information about places,
about roads, and so forth.
So we are really excited
by the opportunities
that this presents
going forward.
Let me leave you with a few
thoughts about the future.
As we tackle the
problems today in order
to make the on-demand
economy thrive,
where do we see this going
forward in the future?
Imagine if you could predict
how many people were going
to show up at the Yankees
baseball game that is happening
in a few hours, or maybe in a
few days, and how many of them
would need a ride-sharing
service to get to that place,
or how many of them would need
a ride-share back and from which
locations.
It is easy-- we heard
the example of Pokemon Go
where the demand
they expected was
significantly lower than the
actual demand they observed.
It was 50x the demand they
expected in the best case.
And with Google Cloud, we were
able to very quickly provision
them as we saw that demand.
Because provisioning hardware
and software is something
we have really
nailed with Cloud.
But getting real people
in their cars provisioned
to satisfy demand, there's
some physics involved there.
And that's hard.
So the sooner you can
predict, the more efficient
you will be in order
to capture that demand.
Imagine being able to predict
after a Beyonce concert in Los
Angeles how many people,
once they head home
after the concert at 9:00 PM,
are going to request delivery
of food, and being able to
provision it in such a way
that you can deliver the food to
them within 30 minutes of them
desiring it, and
knowing which restaurant
and what cuisines
they would like
so that the restaurants are also
equipped to handle the load.
These are some of the questions
our partners and our customers
are asking us to help with.
And we are thrilled
at the opportunities
and the challenges
that it presents.
With our knowledge
of the real world
and behavioral insights
into how people behave
in the real world, we
believe we are very well
situated to address some
of these challenges.
Where does that leave
us with another trend
that we see in the future?
How many of you here
would be shocked
if self-driving
cars were providing
ride-sharing services,
say, by 2020?
OK.
A few of you.
So maybe not 2020.
Maybe 3, 4, 5 years.
I feel I'm in fairly good
company here that most of you
think that you would
not be shocked.
The question that
I wondered about
was the problems, the
challenges of economics
that I mentioned earlier.
Does it still apply in the
world where there's no driver?
That it's all self-driving cars,
maybe self-driving vehicles
to deliver food to your
place, or packages,
or drones that can
deliver in your backyard,
in your driveway, or right
in front of your front door?
How does some of the
challenges that we see today
apply in that future which
is not very far away?
If, with five senses, and
the human intelligence,
and a smartphone that can
harness the power of the cloud,
and the real-time
knowledge of the world
human beings still
have problems solving
some of these on
a daily basis, it
would be my guess that
for a robot to solve
them would require more not less
data, more not less services,
more not less information.
Some of the things
that we're doing today,
we're building a
bridge to the future.
If this future were to arrive
where self-driving cars would
show up where you
want them to show up,
when you want them
to show up, you
would need all the services and
the exactness and the precision
that I mentioned in
order for that to happen.
So we're really excited,
as we look into the future,
we're really excited
by those opportunities.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]